novice amid a migration and one clear
goal for European leaders sealing a deal
with Turkey to stop the uncontrolled
influx of migrants into the EU but first
they needed to agree amongst themselves
as Fonzie English led cahaba on the size
island Eilish all Member States agreed
that we must do everything to strike a
deal with the turkey it was very clear
that we need to clarify all legal issues
that everyone is committed to doing that
here begin by denying heightened vine
and Darwin's of Aleph affliction to stop
illegal migration and take back refugees
turkey is demanding a high price more
funds visa-free travel to the EU and an
acceleration of its bid for EU
membership difficult to swallow for many
as Turkish Prime Minister Davutoglu
acknowledged in Ankara on Thursday night
was your little dune the Guru's autopano
me to malaria nice we see there are some
difficulties within the EU to fulfill
these terms we discuss these with
Chancellor Merkel on the phone last week
and with council president tsk when he
was here in Ankara but European leaders
are pushing back they are asking for a
commitment from Ankara that migrants
returned to turkey will be protected in
accordance with international standards
and why leaders struggled to find a deal
human rights activists were already
sounding the alarm in Brussels they fear
a deal with turkey could result in mass
deportations turkey copy considered a
safe country not only because there's a
large cove of human rights violation in
Turkey but also because even when you
look at only if I may say so the Geneva
Convention they're not respecting that
at all despite such concerns outsourcing
the issue of illegal migration to Turkey
is the only plan on the table the
pressure is on now for European leaders
to seal a deal when Turkish Prime
Minister Ahmet Davutoglu joins them in
the negotiations on Friday